Frank, these are... iron sights.
The only knife in the world with iron sights, because I need you to aim that cut right here.
I don't want the same fate as Frank.
Oh, so you don't trust me?
No!
I'm weeks past right, and I've wasted three days on you with a foot in the compost pile.
You try to stab me with chopsticks, you psychoanalyze me with the doki board, which, by the way, cutting boards don't talk, so I don't know how that even...
You told my entire bat story in metaphorical bento flashbacks!
That's...
You owe me.
Now cut me open and wear my skin!
This is insane.
I'm not going to...
This is my final request.
The mold... I can't feel my seeds anymore!
This is what I made the knife for!
Wait, you designed it... to cut tomatoes?
67 layers of Damascus are on a VG-10 core.
Hardened to 61 HRC, so she stays sharp.
And other blades would just go...
Squish!
That tomato!
I slipped on that tomato.
I squished one.
Frank...
He didn't expect life to...
catch up to him so fast.
That's why I made the handle the way it is.
A pistol grip.
No slipping.
Easier to hold with a recessed choil.
I studied your old videos...
Before...
Before the incident.
Perfect for your print script.
And...
NO HARMACY!
Carbon fiber scales with golden foil because I...
I want it to be memorable.
No way that I'll... never be.
I... I even made rivets that looked like her eyes when she was locked in and...
But...
Why would you want to be cut and burn?
Instead of like... I don't know... being cooked.
When the cut happens...
It's irreversible.
You can't uncut something.
And...
I saw that and it got...
A bit scared I guess.
Even something that looks perfect on the outside...
Might not be doing so hot on the inside.
You prepared me?
To prepare you.
Yeah, I guess you could look at it that way.
Sometimes you need to take a step back and...
Invest everything in others winning instead.
And this time...
I guess it's you, microwave cook.
Tell her...
Tell her the third tomato made it too.
Tell her we'll be able to laugh together again.
Now...
Do it!
Cut me open and wear my skin.
Don't miss.
I won't.
Get your knife at Viteramen.com today...
While supplies last.